there's an online petition to get the
Cincinnati Bengals to change their name
to the Cincinnati haraam bays after the
Cincinnati Zoo gorilla famous for well
you know that thing that we all got
upset about that's a grill that made us
forget all about CSUN line the
change.org petition is so close to
getting the 25,000 signatures it needs
to get someone from the Bengals
organization to glance briefly at it
before throwing it in the garbage
comedians a beloved internet martyr like
harambe deserves to have more than just
a football team named after him what is
one of the things that should be renamed
in honor of Harambee Steve Denny's moons
over Harambee yeah yeah grand slam that
cranberry song where she's like I'm
gonna give you an extra hundred points
for committing to the Dolores O'Riordan
tackle Kirk ran Oehler they should
rename that three-year-old so he never
forgets what he did all right
points